[Music]
hey everybody it's gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 310 of the askgaryvee
show and literally before Jesse and I
just went on air or live so you guys
heard it but before this podcast we're
literally talking about the steroids era
baseball hearings in Congress which
because I'm actually gonna go consume
that content which I rarely do it's a
well it's well done large you tell the
Vayner nation who you are and what you
do I'm Jesse dinner and I run a company
called loony and we do packaging for
e-commerce friends helping ecommerce
friends design their unboxing experience
and source and manage all the stuff they
need to get it shipped out the door and
obviously if you're watching this and
not listening to it you see a huge the
outer packaging of empathy we're gonna
do an unboxing an IG TV after this show
we we are such proud users of your
wonderful company at empathy wines
empathy wines calm order now and I have
really enjoyed that experience and just
from a visual has been remarkable let's
take a step back how did you get into
this business well I I am I started my
first business on 16 and have been and
went to school for industrial design
later on it's I've always basically been
in testing or not I'm a real kid yep and
then your formal education wasn't it
that's traditional education is still
tinted as a process I went to three
years of high school did end up going to
college my parents were strict about
that until I dropped out of that
experience as well but I need go to
college did you to college because they
wanted you to they were like this seems
important to you and from the Midwest it
wasn't like it was too old right it was
too wrong so I did go to college leave
your parents today would have a
different perspective um not really
you will I do I definitely do like I
feel real quick and I apologize for
interrupting but this is my number one
thesis right now yeah I know this you're
not supposed to ask a lady but this is
important and how old are you I'm 31
perfect
you do believe that as a 31 year old
right now I don't have a family
yeah you don't get correct yeah you do
leave right now as you sit here today
that when the time comes
let's just play here for fun I want to
eat seven years here that you're not
going to be passionate for your kids to
go to college I don't think I'm gonna
care whether they graduate from college
I think that the actual experience of
going to wherever you want to go to get
the education you want to get is really
important and sometimes that's gonna be
at college sometimes gonna be other
places but the concept that you need a
piece of paper at the end to say I'm a
valid person to get this next job or
this next experience I don't think it's
funny the reason I'm asking is I
genuinely believe you and definitely I
believe let's say the 21 year old year
like just the reason people still was
like oh that my admire is on the cusp
there's people raved younger who are
like definitely not gonna do it they're
doing glamour school and all this other
stuff right but then as parents yeah
yeah so I think college is held up by
parents ideology oh yeah so it's gonna
take I'm really curious and I genuinely
believe we're probably thirty years away
from it really collapsing yeah because
the parents won't force yeah the pig I
think parents will senator kept by like
this is gonna throw a lot of people yeah
I'm pumped to send my kids to college
yeah I just don't think it's required I
doesn't watch them and reverse any how
near them with my advice and let them do
their thing that's that's where I'm at I
got to the frame I think we're in a
we're in a shifting mindset on that now
I think parents any parents who have
little kids right now are not going to
be as pushy about going to coach because
they're also going to understand the
financial equation if you're a parent
and you have a little kid right now and
you recognize you've got 15 years about
digging yourself out a student that
you're not about to push your head right
off gotta Morty's couldn't agree more
and I remind people I this woman the
other day yelling at me literally in the
street about [ __ ] you about College and
I looked at her and I was like so pumped
because she's going off and I'm like
okay this is gonna be epic why the [ __ ]
is nobody filming me I was so pissed and
I looked at her and said you do know
that people used to think that a woman's
place was at home raising the family
right
and her face right and I wish someone
was I said the hell does that have to do
with anything I said it has to do with
ideology yeah
you can't rationally tell me why every
person should go to college right things
are you emotionally view the world that
way yeah
in 1964 an enormous amount of men in
America a K all of them thought a woman
should stay at home yeah yeah like RI
are things that we put on a pedestal
change they crumble quickly and it's not
what you actually need to do what you're
trying to do next right like and I think
that that's a question we often like we
get in these tracks in life and we think
like it's um it's upgrades it like when
you're when you're like a little kid
you're trying to get your next grade and
get the gold star and I think that some
of that behaviors so like ingrained in
us that it seems important like I start
wrecked and also like that mentality of
like you start something you ought to
finish it right well like that when does
that break down when does that stop
serving you and couldn't agree more and
you also know like fast testing and it
doesn't work move on yeah everything is
a contradiction yeah I mean imagine
being somebody in 1954 in America as a
kid looking at your parents saying I'm
not going to church on Sunday because
most of the country did yep nobody does
yeah like I mean anyway nonetheless
yes college is brand yeah and that's
what we're actually talking about in
trouble yeah it is and and it's not
discussed often how like top schools
have a lot of value in terms of what
that degree could do but then they're
like chunk of like that eighty five
percent under that is like potentially
just like Cruz shaking their head yeah
it's been a big nuance that I've been
saying which is yeah I'm not going to a
top-15 school yep cuz I still think the
ROI is there and then also what's your
degree right like what are you if you if
I was trying to be a doctor like I would
have finished my degree course in design
does that last do you care whether I
went to that lesson do you feel like
this box is less valid because I'd made
mitting I did not finish my last year's
Design School you and Minnie didn't
finish last year of Design School is
like one of the most important data
points of me thinking I like exactly
because I think it takes courage and
self-awareness yeah to to I don't even
get me started on people that go to
school for entrepreneurship yeah
I mean it's all time it's all time like
it's all time and it's all time but
that's why I went to design school
because I recognized I wanted to do
business but I tried to teach myself a
skill that I knew wouldn't come innately
to me which was some of this design like
product launch stuff but it like being a
person who loves business and design
school is like its own form of to pursue
there and like people are presenting
work and you're like but no one's gonna
buy that and everyone's like that's not
why we're here
for fun that snicker from sanad we we
met when I spoke at a college that's
entire thesis is the entrepreneurial
college and America yeah Gary [ __ ] you I
went to Babson it was awesome like cool
Babson's amazing and everybody learns
different but like really break yourself
down and ask yourself fifteen years
later what was taught in the classroom
yeah I know sister Olson that's all yeah
I'm just on emotional about this it's
not super complicated I know so surround
yourself like back to there why the top
schools sometimes you know it's like
potentially might be worth it think
about we can go to school for based on
here in this round or or go work for
free at 18 for the number one person in
that craft instead of being lucky yeah
yeah
bumping into the next Jimmy Iovine once
you get [ __ ] grab Jimmy I means coffee
for [ __ ] 18 months for free that's
not who you surround yourself with you
surround yourself with great people in
our workplace every single person that
wants to be in design product right now
that's a fan of mine should email you to
work for free for you I believe that we
have a great internship program we
actually pay amazing segue actually suit
we're already jamming way too much I
wanted to establish this entrepreneurial
as a kid sixty what was your first
business selling t-shirts on my parents
basement of screen-printing where did
you grow up detroit love already but
that's already love i already love that
we're come on classic cars that are
doing body workers whether they're
second john really you're really trying
to bring it here
to Chevy c10 truck Orange Dukes of
Hazzard Orange ya go to design school
yeah you drop out and do what drop out
and it's 2009 it's a boon of like Gen 1
using product launching companies yes do
a Kickstarter in 2009 when Kickstarter's
for Nestle
yes raised $13,000 realize that that's
exactly how much a school term cost at
the time realize I could make $13,000 as
opposed to spend it that's pretty much
when in my mind I dropped out and then I
went to school for another six months
um do another Kickstarter 18 months
later or maybe a year later raised
$250,000 and then that was a launch
point for taking that first product I
had to learn on have 18 months about
crowdfunding that made you successful it
was a lock or was it serendipity or Wow
a lot about storytelling so so like so
Kickstarter is like a genuine direct to
consumer marketplace right like it's
someone going on and being like hey
world I've got a thing I want to give me
money for it do you trust me do you like
is gonna be an interaction or some
communication yeah so we so my I
realized that the reason from that first
campaign we had 188 backers in the
second campaign me over 3000 I think if
memory serves and in between those two
periods of time it realized that those
first hundred eighty eight people did
not open their wallets to us because
they actually Wallace was one of the
rewards like because they wanted a
wallet for me they open their wallets to
us because they were like this is such a
great story this person design school
with this idea and so 18 months later is
even better at that told a really
powerful story and and that's the theme
of your business now right I mean yeah
like you know even the meta of this like
when we were kind of doing our thing
you're like I want to be on the show and
I'm like you know what let's do it I'm
like yeah mainly on the fact that you
were smart enough to know the value of
what you're doing right this minute yeah
in itself was something I wanted to
reward yeah because it's almost like you
want to give back to the game yeah
because I also understand it yeah if
that makes sense there's a there's a
there's a meta to this for sure which is
like at each juncture in my career it's
been like how do you learn a thing
actually live the thing build a tool for
other people to do the thing so like we
I learn a part of getting Kickstarter
took it to retail sold it all over the
world and like it was [ __ ] beautiful
like it was like hard and rough and not
good in so many ways we did make money
with it it was like 60 was a success in
the sense that it we shut it down
intentionally that's sometimes what a
success is and so we did that but in
that course of that we learned how to
navigate the environment of custom
manufacturer and packaging how hard it
was to manage a supply chain for a
business with physical product and we
were like this is something we can solve
for that was that was four years ago now
and now we'd make packaging for a lot of
the big econ brands that you know and
the reason why is not because like Lumi
school um casper that's a fun parachute
home al Birds me undies yeah companies
like that in the reason why we work with
them is not because our packaging is so
cool actually it's really that supply
chain gets really complicated yeah and
in packaging you're you're solving a
problem packaging is different the plain
cardboard box you should just be
something that gets something from point
A to point B now it's going to doorsteps
millions of doorsteps every single day
that means that challenges the boxes
like under are different than ever
before like so the packaging world
manufacturing world is really grappling
with what those changes mean and we're
like helping solve those problems but
it's it's kind of I mean I mean but it's
kind of profound like we're in a
profound moment of like how what
packaging means to everyone because you
couldn't even order something like this
directly to your doorstep so relatively
recently yes yeah kind of interesting
what uh you know knowing my audience
what how many years is this company been
around nowhere
what's your newest learnings in the last
six months as an operator as an
executive as an entrepreneur yeah raised
capital yep how what's your current hot
take on raising capital fun terrible the
worst the best current hot take on
raising capital is choose a funding
model that fits your goals so for me
this funding model we're in a space
where like some of our competitors are
in status quo competitors measure their
revenue and the bees as I say like it's
like a big space right so in that kind
of space you can raise capital and it
can be a healthy relationship with that
capital in my first business it was a
arts and
supply that I invented like in a
basement the largest year in that
business was like low you know low
seven-figure revenue if I'd raise
capital in that business big mistake so
fit your funding goal to your friend a
method to your goals personally aka
Cisco venture capital isn't the only
route to business that is the current
like thought process of every scribe I
feel like that's sort of all like yeah I
don't think just ask someone who's doing
it I think that's totally not the case
you agree with me that's like crazy that
every single person thinks that's the
option it is completely insane because
he leaves my face off your face know how
to build a business all they care about
is figuring out how to raise capital I
know from venture capital it's um the
thing is that you would I in the same
way apologize and say that everybody
that in our parents generation only
thought you could start a company by
getting a loan from the bank you can
still get loans from banks by the way
very successfully gotten loans and
funded businesses that way I've done
factoring POS you can go get a big peel
from a retailer factor it put six
figures in by the way that's I mean
vaynermedia this company yeah this
company was started because I hustled an
eighty thousand dollar deal from
Gillette yeah
so you have something which allowed me
to hire Marcus and Zang yeah and Sam
Taggart and we started the company out
of buddy media's conference room so I
didn't have to pay any rent yep and then
sit for six months and then our first
full year was in sunshine Suites a
one-off precursor to we work where I
bartered my time in helping them build
that space for space so for the first 18
months I had no overhead on rent for my
company because I literally started
vaynermedia a two hundred million dollar
revenue business with no funding yep
it's completely possible it's about it's
also money is a way of I left Robby's
money equates when when used properly it
just equates to speed often so so if you
so like sometimes eccentric Apple can
speed something up or sometimes but but
it is definitely like but for 97% of
people it gives them into bad behavior
because any hero can lose money each
month hundred percent and also also the
thing is where do you learn
business fundamentals like I think for
me we I feel like good that we learned
our business fundamentals I joke that
someone that won't find an investor gave
me fast like this is a few years ago
when we were like having a low runway
moment and they were like you've got
like four months runway or something and
I was like in my last business I had 30
days run away for four years like I
don't care like I this is not making me
nervous that I have four months revenue
for most runway like it's not if you
cash management is is king god I love
you cash management King tremendous line
yeah you should put a picture of your
face on Instagram with a quote I really
let you do that you mean right now me I
don't know you said I'm gonna leave that
so since I'm a boy that post photos with
quotes on Instagram you do actually me
to show I might call shipping things
where we just talk all about shipping
things it is like just a ghost ship okay
so we're so geeky like we this stuff
does not get high view count but like it
is there for the people who need it
which is like if you are starting mini
come brand or you're like hey like I am
I am wondering if this product that I'm
thinking of could go to market we're
there to like go through all the geeky
details like tell you the difference of
the different types of tape you could
use how buying a box might take a more
space in your fulfillment center and
cost you on storage etc yeah oh yeah
yeah it's like so story like clear
couldn't couldn't love that concept more
yabbies the background saying that shows
the reason you we are even working
together yeah content is the gateway
drug to business yeah more importantly
you're bringing value to your point
ninety-eight percent of my audience
right now listening isn't gonna watch
that show but for the two percent that
are starting media they're gonna be
public yeah yeah that's what you're
pumped about your pump to go like how do
not pick the wrong tape I'm playing to
figure out how you and travel you're
gonna make sure more of our wine doesn't
continue to break Trouty yeah I don't
like our percentages on breakage so
we're gonna know that version of this
box better be real that's the show I
want to watch but yeah it's some people
the thing that's interesting is like you
know people give me sass about being I'm
like obsessed fast good good you a nice
ass about being the person who's out
there like making boxes like into
content like I like talk about this
stuff so seriously like you do you
really type really quick yeah why do
they give you sass what do they say
they're just like this is is losing
players that judge who haven't actually
executed in their lives driving me about
like your cousin I make like a listen
Karen other entrepreneurs who are like
working on the future of AI or something
or like how's your box company of those
phases and it's like I am like out there
putting out contents about something so
specific and and we're so passionate
about this like pretty do me a favor
when agent I started vaynermedia yeah
all our friends started well-funded
consumer apps how they doing they're all
at a business and so you know when they
were worth millions on paper and
changing the world there's nothing more
gratifying than when you're actually
building a business yeah on business
fundamentals yep
managing cash yep building something
real yeah there's nothing more fun than
having the conversation when you just
decide for fun to razz or sass the [ __ ]
out of them years later when they're
working at some other company yeah
there's a pretty gonna happen to all
these eggs hey is gonna win yeah but one
percent of the people that are sassing
you yeah are gonna be the winners which
means ninety nine percent of them that
are being dicks right now need to be
held accountable by us was it crab them
in four years they want their names I
think you gave Chicanos we went through
Y Combinator and and and I think it was
like fascinating life experience talking
about speed of learning and back to the
school thing for a hot SEC like when you
think about ways to learn information Y
Combinator's three months of your life
and I think that you get a jolt to the
system that like some people might spend
three or four or five years in school
for so I think that when you think about
time or something interesting there but
the stab that I think you could kick out
of is that I have twelve hundred active
YC companies less than a hundred have 50
employees or more that would probably
mean that
than 1-hundred bucket but does that like
not that employee count is a measure of
success but it does kind of speak to
scale and it's kind of fascinating
there's so many companies live from that
program and so few scaling and you know
we look listen welcome you and you
remember our first kind of like why
we're sitting here remember on that
FaceTime or what-have-you yeah like that
was the first time in a very long time
that I was like I want to invest in this
company because that woman yeah
knows what the [ __ ] she's talking about
we strive for that yeah honestly like
like you like I don't know what else to
tell you like anybody's listening to
this podcast right now let's get one
phone number in for sure Facebook
Instagram put your phone numbers in yeah
and let's definitely uh let's definitely
get a question in I am unbelievably
impressed with the utter practicality
and operations DNA that you possess and
now my second conversation with you yeah
I mean it I'm completely blindly a buyer
of your ability to build businesses I
finally I appreciate that and I see that
never yeah I appreciate that you know
kind of helps go to class for it oh my
god I remember once I registered a dual
calm because I was gonna be rad plus
cool rad dual culture world and then
flip the URL this is a real thing I once
worked on for now I still believe that I
can make a word go completely mainstream
and will try to do it at one point in my
life like just completely left field
registered the URL get all the handles
and make it the new leg I completely
believe in that I can prove that even
like a word creation basically like
somebody beat up lit yeah yeah if I made
up a lot of things you gotta be really
proud of you hello Walter its Gary
Vaynerchuk and learning askgaryvee show
[Laughter]
how are you Walter I prefer you do do
that I mean bro if it's gonna bring you
a lot better content thanks for callin
bro where you from what are you about 27
yeah I'm a product of the college
dropout life because I just really found
my passion yeah and so I started to
create a whole bunch of clothing and so
I kind of took a little bit of a turn
because it was becoming more of like a
money thing as opposed to you know it's
like the overall growth and passion of
you know the right looks to do and so
and so I started to look at everything
from the numbers side as opposed to you
know liking the better interests of the
actual brand yep and so now I'm just
trying to essentially start over with my
brand yep
and so you know the biggest thing that I
have for you guys you know would be how
do you start over easily early and often
yeah easily what do you you know
by recognizing it's the easiest thing in
the world able to not take other
people's judgment and if you're willing
to be humble and patient hundred percent
I I shut down one company that I ran for
four and a half years I and I felt like
it was it felt internally like it might
be this really dramatic thing and then
you realize that the world is so like
busy and agnostic toward you absolutely
look about you Owen cares so but it's
like shake good news it's liberating
it's just like go for just let's figure
it out yes and I with all my followers
uh nobody gives a [ __ ] it's like its own
liberating when you
kind of wake up to that then like you
sorry yeah yeah no no like you when you
wake up to the fact that no one really
cares that much about what you've been
doing it's like it's not kind of like oh
like slight bummer and then you're like
wait a sec I can do whatever I want
nobody cared about your big [ __ ]
pimple in the middle of your head in
eighth grade but you thought they did
but they had their own [ __ ] problems
yeah see success or notoriety or like
pressure is predicated on how long
somebody will give a [ __ ] when Prince
dies we give a [ __ ] for a day Yeah right
where's all my homies now about my man
nipsey well give him love that week but
like people move on with their lives
then just the way it is and those are
special people nipsey prince like
special 1% 1% like for the rest of us
what do you think and like no matter how
much your ambitions are to be special
like me like what you equally realize is
nobody gives a [ __ ] how do you start
over easily nobody gives a [ __ ] what are
your alternatives what else you get a
[ __ ] do bro yeah yeah you just
tomorrow's a new day and you and the
stress is internal for you it's less
about so the world is like ready for
your next idea you know and are you
asking like theoretical like the way we
took it or are you asking like physical
like register now like what do you like
yeah I assume it's mental and macro
right it's a hundred percent macro
loving like just for a little bit more
context guys so I grew the company
literally straight from college I
service at six figures yeah little bit
over six months go ahead and I was
strictly from and that was like strictly
from Instagram because of course you
know actually was using that back in
2013 when it started to really take off
yeah it wasn't actually positioned for
brands at that point yes and so I
leverage the best and and to be
completely transparent you guys like it
got caught up in crazy to me because
I've used you know it's like 10k
followers as a shit-ton
yeah right and it just completely threw
my mindset out of whack you got high on
your own supply yeah so you have to
realize yeah bro I get it yeah it's
tough the other thing is like what got
you here won't get you there kind of
thinking or it's just like whatever you
did on that last business that worked
like probably won't work again in the
same way so just unhook from that and
think about what you want to do next
bro
this happens all the time using data
points from here like I have so much
empathy I'm so pumped that you're so
self-aware though you're 27 and you
understand that that's what happened bro
you know me people get into Y Combinator
which is in Silicon Valley we're like
[ __ ] Harvard Stanford all of that in
start-up land and think they've made it
hmm like I'm sure you had classmates in
your class they thought they made it
when they got into YC yeah they haven't
even started yeah how many people
celebrate fundraising yeah maybe we
raised three million bucks party boats
who like yeah dude I get a dude and like
10k in 2013 was like cuz I was there 10k
in 2013 was like having three million
right now yeah dude when I have four
thousand followers on Twitter in 2007
and went to South by Southwest
you would have [ __ ] thought I was
Drake yeah but everything has a moment
so that's exams
why does everything has a moment in you
see entrepreneurs sometimes right try to
recreate an old moment make it so true
super awkward and weird so just like
think about that like think about how
you can't recreate that old moment where
you were and you don't go back to high
school as a college kid to pick up high
school chicks okay yeah Walter Walter
honestly very seriously bro this is a
piece of cake nobody gives a [ __ ] and
you shouldn't give a [ __ ] about their
opinions and you should practice that
yep and it's not right it's like good
news please please please go follow the
boys lifeline they're going to might
appreciate a guy thank you thank you
take care now it's such it's so right
like we have so obviously I like you cuz
within the same school I can see ya from
all the things you're saying it's like
yeah Batum [ __ ] yeah like yeah yeah it
you you you internalize this stuff cuz
it's important to you like if you spent
the last four years working on something
day in doubt it's like to kill it or
something feels impactful people feel
people feel like but then I would have
wasted all my time no you wouldn't know
sitting on something that's already dead
is wasting your time forward yes
completely and in whatever period of
time measure each period of time by how
much you learned in that period of time
if you learn something take that
learning and move on but but the
learning is what you got from macro the
learning like a learning like could be
like you learned that it
fun yeah like forget about like the
literal like I learned mbx is that you
know that was the u-turn how to do
storytelling yeah for sure
another learning is you were just a
[ __ ] knucklehead from 22 to 25 and it
was just [ __ ] fun yeah you had fun
maybe you learned that you like like
what you like like oh I like her name is
sorry I oh I oh I don't like you just
all that learning is pretty pivotal or
you've learned that the friends that you
like having fun with I'm not gonna be
the friends that you're gonna build the
next thing with yeah they want to have
fun for the rest of their lives yeah
yeah all of that super valid but
whatever you take away from that
experience like that's what you got to
move forward into the next one
I love losing micro losses i I just feel
like III I'm a I don't want to go
full-blown and Sam masochist but I think
that like when I find the pain in the
day or like the pain and the month or
the pain in the year of like I'm like
there it is you know like because you
knew it's coming do you think thing so
I'm on board of that now I'm gonna ask
you a real 301 version of this question
okay do you think you even
subconsciously
create it um I think I seek out
situations that that make that make the
pain happen I think I seek out the
situations where I knew I'm not quite
ready and I know that the organization
isn't quite ready or or I'd change
something really fast and I know it's
like a hard left turn and you're gonna
get like your you know your neck yanked
on it
and so but yeah so genuinely believe
it's right yeah like I love what my
executives like you can't do that I'm
like you don't understand I'm in charge
and I think it's right why Jenni like I
understand what's gonna be wrong about
it yeah I understand everyone's gonna
cry I know slack's gonna blow up at
Vayner and be like our fists [ __ ] guy
I know what's gonna happen but it's my
job yes it is your job actually actually
your job so I don't know if people get
that about that role that you're in is
like that's actually your job and people
don't want who work your company if you
aren't able to make those choices but
it's part of the job and it means the
job is painful the difference between a
great CEO and not one is one knows that
they're a parent and one thinks they're
a babysitter yeah it's your job to job
it's your [ __ ] job it's it's a tease
you're completely integral to their role
so I think that I know that the pain is
like you know gonna be created but it's
it does I also think that I think I knew
is life is short right like you wouldn't
you think about life long it's it's a
shortened life and I mean in the sense
that like if I think to myself oh I
could do this thing now or I could do it
in a year I actually think what you're
saying which is a lot of fun for me as
well as like you don't want to regret
what entrepreneurs have and you are
absolutely a purebred entrepreneur in my
opinion which is probably the most
biggest compliment I could give you
we're too scared to look gret not dying
on our own sword yeah yeah the worst
thing that could happen for me is that I
is that what I'm up to gets boring for
me or that that we didn't take enough
risks to find out where the edges really
were of like you do smile you took the
advice of a non entrepreneur absolutely
watching some kind of purest bread
entrepreneurs over financed advice from
somebody that they admire yeah and then
lose and they know in their soul they
lost what somebody else's opinion or
strategy that would literally break my
[ __ ] soul but that's that's you know
if the second thing you're the second
thing you're following someone's advice
so you know you can at one point say
like well it's actually the moment that
you just saw out that's your correct you
realize that you are 100% accountable
for everything I genuinely believe yeah
for real yeah absolutely everything in
his company is my fault yep yep but it's
it's that's that's of the pain line so
that's also where that liberation lies
100% because it's painful we're then and
it's like it sometimes it's like
actually like feels painful but then at
the same time when you realize that then
there's like a calm that's like oh but
that means it's my job to make these
choices and so XYZ you're amazing we're
going to Instagram TV
well Instagram live excuse me to unbox
this empathy wines calm give your give
the website give your show yeah let's do
some right hooks here and then we'll all
right days off you can find us at Lumi
calm hell um I ll um I calm and we have
a podcast called well-made we interview
a lot of entrepreneurs who do
direct-to-consumer hominem and then I
have a show on YouTube matte Limi HQ
called shipping things or soon to be
rebranded to
no [ __ ] okay sorry what what what where
do you put like so listen I actually
think you can bring a lot of value as a
CEO and entrepreneur to my audience
because like I am picking up what you're
putting down which is very rare for me
do you talk about is where's where are
you doing what we just did if anywhere
LinkedIn you anywhere yet or any kind of
not doing that part yet not officially
as part of my brand I just bring candor
to like wherever I'm at but quite a bit
of alias [ __ ] candor yeah
it's just kind of like I don't know how
to be another some joke that I say when
I when I'm really honest someone they're
kind of taking it back is that I just I
have got one mode and they're
experiencing it and it's just this like
so funny people ask me a lot of
different things about where you're
going with this and I'm like I'm just
not capable of not being myself yeah I'm
just not I don't have it yeah it's like
a weird thing to try to explain where
someone's like the why you like them
you're like I don't know why do you wait
here John like why are you like that you
know yeah so I don't know how high are
you a boy Johnny why are you boy like
some people ask things about
personalities it's like laughable mm-hmm
it's an integral tool to just your DNA I
also I don't know I feel like you use
this as well like I feel that humor is a
very under Adam you utilize like
skillset in business like I love being
with someone and just sharing real
information but making it kind of like
funny and in in that way I cannot
believe you just said that literally
yesterday somebody that works at banners
said to me why don't you do more humor
on your content you're so funny
yeah none of your content really shows
that and the only time you even remote
only your vlog shows it when but even
the editors are why are they not editing
more of that in yeah and I'm like you're
right yeah do you rock you're fired but
it's like I think it's a underutilized
skill set because humor is a way of also
like taking tension out of this content
you're out I use it to deliver Frank
information faster as opposed to
starting around issues correct it's just
a great tool it's funny I just realized
something
it's one of the reasons my rasz like a
lot of times I one thing I've learned
actually I've learned it at empathy and
dijanna needs
read it as my partners as my younger
brothers because I've been with them for
a decade it's funny I use humour for
that yeah the bad version historically
for me yeah was razzing to get some of
my own resentment or difficult out
yeah and fine because people would like
that better than this being completely
called out and being like you [ __ ]
suck yeah but if you do it too much the
the 37 little Raza's versus one radical
conversation is worse and I genuinely
genuinely learn that genuinely during
ironic it's very meta doing empathy
whines this adventure project Nath and
John did a very good job communicating
to me of like hey cuz razzing is how I
want to say it it goes into can't be
inventing yeah and other places when you
know somebody super well they can take
it with love and I won't razz like I
won't razz like it's funny you can
always tell how our relationships
building on how much of
samman literally today can walk out of
here realizing we're closer than ever
because of the way I'm raising him on
Babson yeah I wouldn't do that to John
yet but I feel it's emerging ieave him a
compliment on here but I racetam it's
gonna happen compliment it something
else funny actually if you're watching
at home psycho be like shine doesn't
like that semana it's actually the
reverse I actually like Simeon better
than John no it's actually trip so I'm
curious about your opinion on something
seriously what a me bro it's about to go
I'm like I'm not the shaven soon it's
getting amazing in so there's like
something that I feel is also
interesting like as a we joked about
this when I was coming you're like I'm
five feet tall
someone said I looked younger than I
look at some guys you should've seen it
he was like you should comply mr. Mike I
think was a cop or not I gotta talk
about that like when you meet me in
person no matter how you're seeing me
now I look like a teenager and I'm five
feet tall um even though I am 31 so the
thing is in business that's not always
like the bestest you know like for me
that's just when you're at the mercy of
the old establishment right it's the
bestest when you're not right so humor
though is actually my way of like
disarming people with that so you were
like someone is like oh whoa like I'm
this five foot tall like girl person is
being like real serious with me about
business right now but she's making it
funny like I don't know Daffy
like I don't you know it's like a you
kind of can disarm someone's um like we
conceived
yeah what they're know what they're
Donna lines I think he looks funny
yesterday I was in a meeting with a lot
of leaders in the department and the way
I disarm people is actually by proving
to them even though I'm a CEO of nine
hundred people that I actually know what
the hell's going on yeah there's nothing
more fun to me than going to a meeting
where it's a group of senior people who
don't interact with me every day and
they first of all especially cuz of the
Gary B thing they're not even sure if I
even run this company yeah and then when
I roll in and I'm just talking and I
slip in something that like there's no
way outside of being in that little crew
then you would know that and I say it it
blows their faces off no really it's
really like I love that I I agree with
disarming or really changing the tune in
a room yeah and I do use humor to your
point and one of the other things I love
just a brick value of something that
somebody may want to do you will change
a room very quickly when you're the most
senior person in a company when you
prove to them that you're not confused
no different than when your parents when
you thought you were doing something
that and they no idea about yeah that
they make a joke about it they're like
my school cop yeah they're like yeah
like Stan and you're like [ __ ] how did
you know I've been hooking up with Stan
yeah you know that kind of [ __ ] like I
that's it yeah very good move for
executives because what it does is hey
they feel great that you actually know
what the hell's going on yeah be they're
like oh [ __ ] I might not be able to
trick this person as much as I think
there's a lot of value going on to say
yeah with humor it's like okay yeah
there's a there's a whether it's self
deprecation or humility there's all
these different little things going on
in a room yeah so finding your style
though like you you you know people
people often ask me like whether like I
I'm a very jokey person like I use
physical comedy a lot like rip you're
tripping yes I'm calm I'm tripping and
like materpiece ripped each other
it's funny like tripping people trip
yeah your auditions let's talk about
pantsing who in this room by show of
hands knows what pantsing is I mean who
doesn't Wilson a monarchy so so anybody
who doesn't know he does which is why I
asked him is unpunctual II there were
girls in my high school they got pantsed
in the middle of the hallway yeah they
got some really politically incorrect
[ __ ] yeah we would say it was like alive
and well for all of my middle school in
high school
or like in the book like what did people
call when you do the books you just like
slap the books at someone's hands like
an [ __ ] in the room when I was in
high school I think it movie thing guys
could where were boxers like hardcore
boxers like no other underwear was
acceptable not tidy whities not like
whatever whatever boxer briefs thank you
only thing acceptable was baggy boxers
the amount of my friends thank god this
never happened to me the amount of my
sense that got pantsed in the hallway
yeah and both shorts and boxers went
because of the nature like I feel like
modern-day pantsing because brief said
like other things was everybody who got
pantsed got naked Oh like I feel like
female pantsing didn't happen that way
you would see the underwear in nineteen
is's and bolts that's what's going at
what high school I love this kid like
there's so much bullying in tension I'm
like there was [ __ ] pants like a 94
comedy like so I like walk into my
office and then be like you know I'm CEO
like they'll like have like some big
news again not great I can't walk in
there Bob LA and then like going out of
this I shouldn't stand up cuz I have
another thing but they're like I'll be
on the phone and I'll be like uh and
like fall down like as though the news
killed me
would be like it's fine nice such a good
leader yeah no really I'm really proud
of these rules he fall our job are you
falling down dead Jane Lee is coming to
my team number one thing the number one
thing that I believe I do for a living
is the CEO of this company is eliminate
fear of my place it is the number one
thing I do everyone's more everyone's
more productive when they're not fearful
kissed which is you're not thinking so
doing he's so sick early he's also
making y'all this is actually my Mary
this is my macro thought of being a
businessman yeah my goal one of my
absolute top goals is to redefine what a
successful businessperson looks like
yeah why can't you be kind
yeah I can't you be empathetic yeah why
can't you be such a good leader that you
spend all your time like like I love how
like and I know you already know they
you know what you were saying but some
people like oh he uses eliminating fear
to click them to work harder like it's
not a trick it's authentic it just is
like real talking about but yeah every
angle
hey I'm for the angle dick don't yeah I
meant I'm into authentically like it's
basically the funny thing it's like I'm
it reminds me of just like dancing no no
just acting like you know so weird like
we were like basically yes when when we
design a supply chain efficiently it's
also greener like there's no macro
troubles you represent more like how are
you gonna make your here it's like we're
gonna truck it less miles we're gonna do
basic stuff it's the same way that like
it's the same thinking which is there's
no trick to you're so lost yeah yeah get
louder yeah do me a favor yeah if you
can do anything for me yeah get louder I
can absolutely the right framework you
know what is needed in the business
world yeah get louder your practicality
is that like your mix of black and white
and gray mm-hmm of like teeth and heart
mmm is exactly the framework of what I
believe needs to be the pedestal yeah of
executives and entrepreneurs in the
world yeah thank you
[Music]